i was trying to casually just pop into
frame and you could still see a piece of
my arm anyway this is just a little
video it's like a little update video if
you will i haven't really done a video
just kind of
talking
directly to you guys usually i'm sitting
on a couch or i'm going around vlogging
and when i use this camera for some
reason i don't know what it is about
this camera but it makes me want to talk
to you guys in a more personal level i
don't know this is the camera i'm using
hello hi hey i'm not sure how to explain
it but this camera
makes everything seem like it has to be
real professional and scripted even
though i don't know ever script anything
i was about to shoot an sk episode but i
thought i would just
sit and chat with my friends a lot of
you guys have been asking me why i
haven't posted videos lately uh i have
been sick for like three
weeks almost i don't i don't like the
flu i had a cold
i still have an ear infection i can't
hear out of this ear and i've never
really had that great of hearing because
i used to go to so many concerts when i
was younger like i went to like five
concerts a week which is a lot of shows
how many camo book bags does one human
need
one two four obviously on that note of
not being able to hear i have been
putting subtitles on everything really
enjoying this tv show can't hear it some
of you also might not know that i have a
more than one youtube channel the reason
i do have these channels is because i
like to kind of categorize my content so
here's all my youtube channels so if i
haven't been posting here it's probably
because i've been posting here
this is my couch it's red i sometimes
think to myself justine why did you get
a red couch my entire apartment is white
everything i really love sort of the
modern look but i wanted a couch so bad
in this room that i went online it was
like what place can deliver me a couch
immediately like today so i found this
website i found this couch the other
stipulation is it had to be a pull-up
couch because my sister jenna comes and
stays with me quite often is it bad that
i'm getting winded just talking i don't
think i've recovered from this sickness
yet i'm still working on it anyway
the couch
forgot what i was gonna say i also
am extremely forgetful i'm working on
sort of a book telling you guys kind of
like the story of how i got to where i
am today here's the problem i can't
remember anything so i'm really hoping
that uh my friends have a better memory
than me because i'm gonna have to go and
interview them all and say do you guys
remember
what happened not because i drank it's
not because i've done drugs the hardest
drug that i've ever done is actually
currently i think i'm taking uh some
amoxicillin for my for my ear
i just have a really crappy memory today
i tweeted about minecraft i wanted to
know what texture resource pack to get
completely forgot that i asked you guys
the question took a shower when it got
ready put some makeup on came back to my
replies i'm like what are you guys
talking about these are crazy oh you
know just answering the question that i
asked you guys on twitter so before i
shoot this ask ij episode i wonder if
you guys have any questions i'll leave
them in the comments below i usually
take my questions all from twitter
because it's so easy to do i just say
hey hi what do you want to know so weird
because i don't know if i'm talking low
because when you can't hear just just
try this for me stick your fingers in
your ear and then talk like you hear
yourself talking and the sound of my own
voice like i kind of want to
stop it just
it's different when you can hear it
outside of your head but it's inside of
your head it's like just shut up shut up
shut up
i also saw the lego movie last night it
is one of my favorite movies i'm
probably gonna make another video about
that so i won't even get into it i
am obsessed and i hear the cops
i don't know what else i want to say i
don't think i have anything else to say
i hope you guys had a good valentine's
day stage you guys have a great
president's day i don't know i think i i
think i'm still
in a delirious state of
whatever i don't want to be able to hear
myself in my head anymore stop if
anybody else has a sickness right now i
hope you get well i'm really gonna stop
talking now make sure you guys check out
my last video i did um jenna marbles was
kind enough to come out and do a
sasquatch hunt with me and my sister
jenna so
it was really fun i had a great day i'm
gonna go edit this video now and
cut uh my name is jenna and i'm here on
squatch watch i'm an optics engineer